hey there friends you want to see
something really cool check this
out this is a POI flower one of my very
favorite POI tricks it's eye-catching
bold and impressive to watch thing is
I'm pretty sure that I can teach you how
to do this in less than 30 minutes not
including the time it's going to take
you to watch this video Let's see if I'm
right
Drex here from Drex Factor po sharing
with you the love of Po spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today we are breaking down one of my
favorite poy tricks in a really really
quick lesson but before we dive in I
just want to give a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyrro tery Toys
spinballs and Ultra poy for helping to
make the videos on this channel possible
you can learn more about all these
awesome companies and the work that
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to the non- business
friend of the channel Becca beonin thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission so
straight up PO flowers are a personal
favorite they open up a lot of freedom
of movement they take up a huge volume
and well they just look pretty cool and
as I've been working with some of my
private lesson students I've been coming
across new ways of teaching them such
that I'm pretty sure that I can teach
this type a poy flow in 30 minutes or
less now your results May Vary no one
lesson is going to work perfectly for
everybody but I'm pretty sure that this
is going to be a technique that's going
to work for a lot of people ground rules
before we dive in though I'm going to be
giving you this lesson in several steps
do not move on to the next step until
you can get at least 10 reps of whatever
I'm teaching you in the previous step
that'll make sure that you've actually
built up all the muscle memory that you
need to move on to the next step this
sequence is really really important
don't try to rush ahead and real quick
I'm going to lay down just a little bit
of theory as to what is going on in this
flower and what exactly a POI flower is
you don't need to know any of this stuff
to get down this poy trick so if you
want to skip it feel free you can jump
ahead to this time code right here all
right so there can be a lot going on in
POI flowers so there are three specific
things I want you to keep your eye on as
we talk about this particular trick
those are as
such number one the PO and hands are
traveling around a circle in opposite
directions and reaching the top and
bottom of that Circle at exactly the
same time in the PO world we have a
thing that we refer to as timing and
Direction and there are four separate
modes that this can happen in the
particular mode that we're looking at
for this flower is together opposite or
butterfly and yes that does mean that
there are several other variations on
the flower that I'm teaching you today
number two each individual hand and POI
are moving around in the same direction
with the poy completing multiple beats
for every single beat that the hand
completes
[Applause]
[Music]
so without getting down the pattern with
the hands well the flowers aren't really
going to happen so let's start here so
we want to make sure that we're going
through four specific positions as we
move our hands around the first with our
hands parallel pointing straight down to
our feet and extended as far down as we
can get the second with our arms
straight out to either side even in
height with our shoulders the third with
our hands reaching as high as we can get
above our head and the fourth with our
arms crossed at shoulder level so again
that's down out up crossed down out up
crossed see if you can get between these
four positions 10 times once you get to
a spot where you're comfortable moving
your hands between all these four
positions we're going to take out the
dime stops and just have our hands move
smoothly and continuously through these
circles we still have those four
positions present but they're kind of
blurred into the bigger Circle and
that's exactly how we want it for our
flowers once again I want you to do 10
repetitions moving your arms around in
this pattern before we move on to the
next step let me show you this exercise
from a few different
[Music]
angles
[Applause]
step two adding extensions awesome so
now that your hands understand the basic
movement that we need in order to
perform our flowers we're going to start
getting our POI involved specifically by
adding the POI in as what we would call
extensions so that the POI are just
sticking straight out from our arms and
basically acting as extensions of them
clever name right so at this point I
would recommend wrapping the poy around
your hands usually you can get them to
wrap around at least twice and then
letting out one coil so you still have
one coil Wrapped Around Your Hands but a
little bit of the PO to work with from
here I want you to go ahead and produce
those same circles with your arms going
around but you're probably going to have
to adjust your speed just a little bit
to make those po perfect extensions of
your arms if you find that the PO you're
going limp as you're going across the
top here you need to speed your arms up
and if you find that the PO are going
super wild as they go up and over you're
moving your hands too fast you need to
find the goldilock Zone that's halfway
between those two points again see if if
you can get in 10 reps with your PO at
half length and then work to extend them
all the way to full length again you
might find that you have to make a
little bit of an adjustment in terms of
the speed of your arms and po but again
we're looking to have the POI going
straight out as extensions of your arms
all the way from the shoulder also at
this point you might be finding that
you're having some problems across the
top having the poy run into each other
here's how to fix that you want to think
that as you're going through the top
here you have one hand on top of the
other whichever hand is on top the top
of that PO is going to be pointing a
little bit at you and the bottom hand is
going to have the PO pointed a little
bit away from you like so if you need a
deeper lesson on how to do this I
actually did do a video on it that I
will go ahead and link to down in the
description as well as up in the cards
but suffice to say from the side you
want the two planes of your POI to kind
of look like an X once again we're
looking for 10 reps of this exercise and
when we get that down it's time to move
on to the next step once again let me
show you this exercise from a few
different
[Music]
[Applause]
angles
[Music]
step three Butterflies from the wrists
so in our last step we learned how to
create big circles with our arms and POI
that originate from our shoulders now
we're going to try creating smaller
circles that originate from our elbows
instead here's how start off with those
big circles once again and as you're
going around try and see if you can
localize the movement to just your
elbows the Poise should be able to just
follow along as you're doing this again
we're looking for 10 repetitions of this
pattern once you get comfortable
creating these circles from your elbow I
want you to see if you can create the
circles from your wrists Instead at this
stage it's going to be really tempting
to keep your hands far apart in order to
keep the POI from having any possibility
of running into each other but I want
you to Buck that Temptation and Instead
try and see how closely together you can
keep your hands if you can touch your
hands together that's great even better
if you can get them to cross each other
just slightly again we're looking for 10
reps of this and once you have down 10
reps of this pattern with your wrists
which we call the butterfly well you're
ready to move on to the next step and
here's that exercise from a few
different
[Music]
angles
step four big circle little circle
awesome so now that you can do both big
circles from your shoulders as well as
little circles from your wrists you're
ready to go back and forth between them
and the beginnings of that flower are
going to start to appear so key to doing
this is thinking that you're alternating
between shoulders wrists shoulders
wrists so again start off big thinking
shoulders maybe get in one two three
reps and then one two three reps at the
wrists one two three reps at the
shoulders one 2 three reps at the wrists
and then see if you can get down to just
one one two with the shoulders one two
at the wrists one two at the shoulders
one two at the wrists and then just see
if you can go straight back and forth
between them thinking shoulders wrists
shoulders wrists shoulders wrists
shoulders wrists where exactly do you
make the switch from the big circle to
the little circle I'm so glad that you
asked remember as we do the big circles
that involve making them from our
shoulders we have that point where our
wrist cross across the middle here
that's where you want to do the little
circle there that's where you want to
switch to that wrists size circle right
as your arms are crossing each other at
shoulder level we still want to have the
down out and up but when we do the cross
part that is where we add those little
circles make sense again we are looking
for 10 reps going through switching
between big and little circles big and
little circles when you got 10 of these
down in a row well you're ready for the
final step of this process and again
here's that exercise from a few
different
[Music]
angles
[Applause]
step five Petals on the outside all
right so by now this probably has at
least a passing resemblance to the
flower that I showed you at the very
beginning of this lesson and we just
have one more step to do see that little
circle that we're doing when our arms
cross we can think of as being a petal
for these inpin flowers we now just need
to add Petals on the outside to complete
that picture so to do that let's
actually practice right quick by
starting with our big circles from our
shoulders once again and what I'm going
to ask you to do is pause at that moment
when your arms are straight out to
either side even with your shoulders
this is one of the four positions that
we drilled in that first step and I want
you to just let the Poise spin around
your hands once just once we don't want
to hang out here we want to think big
pause big pause big pause as we go back
and forth between these awesome so then
all we really have to do at this point
is go back to our little circle big
circle little circle big circle and add
that pause on the outside so think we're
doing little circle pause on the outside
little circle pause on the outside we
just want to make sure that we're still
doing pieces of that big circle in
between both of them awesome so our
final step here is just that you're
going to try and get in 10 reps going
back and forth between those little
circles in the middle and reaching out
to get those Petals on the outside as
well
make sure that you're still reaching
down and around and up and over in
between each of those two spots and if
you want bonus points see how far you
can get your arms to cross across the
middle there to really make the petals
in each of those flowers pop Here's the
final version from a few different
[Music]
angles
and if you made it this far
congratulations you learn your PO
flowers Wicked so did these techniques
work for you if so please post video of
yourself doing this trick online and
make sure to tag me I'll come around and
leave you some encouragement for having
done all that wonderful hard work and if
you're inspired now to explore POI
flowers including other timing Direction
modes of them in luck because that is
the topic of the flow Circle for this
month the flow circle is an exclusive
weekly lesson that's available only to
my patreon supporters and this month the
theme is poi flowers we'll be exploring
multiple timing and Direction modes how
to turn with flowers different
techniques that can assist in putting
flowers together and have an entire
lesson that's just devoted to getting
down flowers in Split Time same
direction if you'd like access to those
lessons you can sign up over at
patreon.com Factor poy the first lesson
is available right now go check it out
also did you get stuck anywhere in this
lesson leave me a comment and let me
know and I'll see if I can help you
through it in the meantime make sure to
like comment share and subscribe so
other people can find this video and you
can help my channel
[Music]
grow this video would not be possible
without my amazing supporters on P
patreon in particular I'd love to give a
shout out to my flow patrons who are
listed on screen right now thank you all
so much for supporting my channel my
work and my mission and if you all out
there would like to support that mission
as well again you can go sign up at
patreon.com drexfactor poy and help me
make more videos like this one thanks in
advance and if you'd like to go deeper
into the rabbit hle of poy Trix I have
an entire series that I did during the
pandemic teaching people how to spin poy
right from the start and taking them
through to intermediate po SP
I will go ahead and leave a link to that
playlist down in the description as well
as up here on screen if you're watching
on YouTube thank you so much for
watching make sure to give yourselves an
opportunity to get out and flow today
and I'll see you with a new video real
soon take care now peace